في يوم
السبت بتوجيهات مني
، نجحت الولايات المتحدة في
تنفيذ غارة جوية في كابول ، أفغانستان ،
قتلت أمير
القاعدة إيمان الزويري ،
تعلمون أن الزويري كان زعيم بن لادن
، وكان معه طوال الوقت الذي
كان فيه الرجل الثاني نائبه.  في
وقت الهجوم الإرهابي 911.
كان متورطًا بعمق
في التخطيط لـ 9 11.
أحد أكثر
الهجمات التي أدت إلى مقتل
2977 شخصًا على الأراضي الأمريكية
لعقود من الزمن كان العقل المدبر وراء
الهجمات ضد الأمريكيين بما في
ذلك قصف الولايات المتحدة.  كول في عام 2000 الذي
قتل 17 بحارًا أمريكيًا وجرح
العشرات
، لعب دورًا رئيسيًا في
تفجير سفارتي الولايات المتحدة في كينيا وتنزانيا
مما أسفر عن مقتل
224 وإصابة أكثر من
400 آخرين.
أعضاء الخدمة
الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين والمصالح
الأمريكية ومنذ أن قدمت الولايات المتحدة
العدالة في بن لادن قبل 11 عامًا ،
أصبح الظواهري
قفزة  دير القاعدة ، القائد
عن الاختباء ، قام بتنسيق فروع القاعدة
وفي جميع أنحاء العالم بما في ذلك
تحديد الأولويات لتوفير
التوجيه العملياتي
الذي يدعو إلى هجمات
ملهمة ضد أهداف أمريكية ، قام بتصوير مقاطع فيديو
بما في ذلك الأسابيع الأخيرة التي دعت
أتباعه لمهاجمة
الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤنا
الآن
تم تحقيق العدالة ولم يعد هذا
الزعيم الإرهابي من
الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم بحاجة
إلى الخوف من القاتل الشرير والحازم
، وتواصل الولايات المتحدة
إظهار عزمنا وقدرتنا
على الدفاع عن الشعب الأمريكي ضد
أولئك الذين  تسعى لإلحاق الأذى بنا